after V ramaswami attacked Nikki for
saying that she I don't know she was
giving some remark about the military
and V said you're bought and paid for by
the military industrial complex you're
corrupt you took money from Boeing Chris
Christie comes out and white nights for
Nikki Haley we're now 25 minutes into
this debate and he has insulted Nikki
Haley's basic intelligence not her
positions her basic intelligence she
doesn't know regions she wouldn't be
able to find something on a map that his
three-year-old could find look if you
want to disagree on issues that's fine
and Nikki and I disagree on some issues
but I'll tell you this I've known her
for 12 years which is longer than he's
even started a vote in the Republican
primary and while we disagree about some
issues and we disagree about who should
be president of the United States what
we don't disagree on is this is a smart
accomplished woman you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take this
Nikki actually played it off pretty well
but he he's picked his side